you are such a force in this series i
was so
impressed with you um you know you have
said that
you had never read a female character
like sheila
what makes her so unique
there is obviously an insight to her
with her inner narrative that we see
um that was just so moving to me you
know
it's about appearances and about you
know
how we all present a certain way and i
think this
for men all women as a as a human
condition you know and really
kind of you know we meet this woman at a
breaking point and she's obviously very
ill
and she is she's she's not you know she
she's um
but you still i want to root for her
despite a lot of her kind of
unconventional
things she does and the way she behaves
but she's kind of living in this space
of a lie
so more lies you know a little lie here
a little stealing there whatever it may
be
it's sort of an extension of all of the
all of the um all of the lies she's
already living in
um but like any great character you see
and it will read in a novel or a show or
whatever you know you want to root for
them
despite absolutely you definitely
believe you definitely want to root for
her
um
[Laughter]
the inner monologue can be you know
definitely there were some dark elements
and negative elements where there's some
moments so that you could really relate
because i feel like i could it's
incredibly uncomfortable it's
like annie wiseman our show runner she
would like be in her car i'd be like
where are you going she's like i just
felt a little uncomfortable i'm like you
wrote this what are you doing
but um you know that's what's
interesting and that's what's
terrifying about doing a performance
like this is is going to those
deeply uncomfortable places but you know
uh
i it was also a joy you know and
that we had an incredible director craig
gillespie who did our pilot who brought
such
tension and urgency to her addiction and
her illness which
to me has never you know it's it's it's
not really
been dealt with i think in such a kind
of intimate and emotional way it's not
lurid it's just very
it's very scary and dark and how it
should be it's a horrible illness it's a
horrible addiction
um and he was just so brilliant in
bringing the visual stimulation for that
which was very hard to do and something
i have not seen before so well i have to
talk about the aerobic scenes did you
enjoy those because they look like such
an intense workout
i loved them they were you know i
started training um a couple of months
in advance with a
choreographer jennifer hamilton who just
brought such humor
and warmth and patience with me i'm not
a dancer i'm not good at that i'm not
coordinated all of that was very learned
and she figured out
what looked good and her evolution is
sheila starts she's not particularly
good and then she gets stronger and
stronger
and finding the other layer to it was
finding sheila's
inner voice which is so destructive but
making it turning it into this
compelling
you know energizing convincing kind of
leader which those exercise gurus have
whether it is you know
tracy anderson or you know tarantumi or
whomever they they have a quality that
is captivating and gets
their you know gets this following so
it's
true you know when you think of like
1980s aerobics you think of celebrity
workout videos from jane fonda suzanne
summers was there someone in particular
that you really drew inspiration from
it's a deeply personal story for annie
so she was incredibly candid with me
and then all of those entrepreneurs you
know i was in the 90s so i did videos
with cindy crawford and
but um the 80s space was so unique
because it was where a lot of women
found this ability to be entrepreneurs
through the wellness space
and find economic independence you know
who
really came from a different time from
the you know from the feminist movement
but who were perhaps you know kind of
disillusioned from that
so it's a very it's a really interesting
period for women
i think um what was it like for you
shooting a series that takes place in
the 80s because i have to tell you your
hair
was so perfect it was so easy and i
it's like its own character i could not
stop staring at it it was awesome
yeah again annie had such a specific
vision and initially i
i was like wow this is too much and then
by day three i'm like bigger
bigger bigger bigger i was like i got it
and um it it's like anything it's such a
great
piece of the puzzle is putting that
together and and making it not look
retro
making it not look like a costume but
authentic you know
back in the day leotards that fabric was
not available like women were finding it
and sourcing it and making their own
leotards like it was really
it was of that era so it really we
wanted to have that incredibly authentic
look to it which cami just went above
and beyond with the detail like i i mean
every leotard is within a millimeter
a millimeter of its life fitted to me
and
it's you know it's like a suit of armor
you have the tights on and all that but
when you know when you're actually all
in it it's
uh it just takes you to you know it
transforms you time travels you back to
where you need to be
yeah well it was so it was so good on so
like it was emotional it was funny the
dark comedy i just
enjoyed it so much so congratulations
it's so nice getting to talk to you
again you're really sweet thank you
you